[Musique]
et on voit un Maxime concentré comme
Jaja avec le maillot de l'équipe de
France un maillot qu'il faudra bien de
changer puisqu'il n'a que deux étoiles
c'est pas de bol c'est un maillot
dimanche soir on peut le mettre à la
poubelle attention quand même
Magnus qui s'est un peu mieux coiffé
aujourd'hui il s'est fait beau et ça y
est le timer qui est parti les Magnus en
arrière-plan toujours un peu dégueu
ouais c'est pas super rangé chez lui
après il fait un peu comme il veut s'il
veut ranger il range il veut pas ranger
il range pas il y a pas de mal chacun
fait ce qu'il veut avec sa chambre après
tout il a déjà plus d'une trentaine
d'années ce n'est pas à nous d'aller
discuter de la manière dont il devrait
ranger sa chambre cela ne nous regarde
pas est-ce que les deux s'entendent bien
écoute les pieds de Maxime vont où ils
veulent et c'est souvent dans la gueule
Magnus qui calcule de 06 chacun il fait
fou prendre des quatre et oui je joue la
sécurité Magnus il a peur et c'est
normal qui n'aurait pas peur du champion
du monde entier il faudrait être fou
pour pas être inquiet quand on joue
contre Maxime
et Dame des cinko et surf 3 fois 4 maxi
mégalise ouais ça se passe bien ce début
de game ça rentre déjà une seconde
minute de retard et oui ça fait des
petits signes de tête c'est un peu
dégoûté quand même là côté Magnus oui
bon retour de jouer avec caroanna et il
revient à l'année prochaine frérot manus
qui a pris toutes les cases ici roi des
quatre il va se diriger vers F5 et il
est en train de dominer là il est en
train de dominer sévèrement Magnus
Maxime qui est en train de se faire
complètement retourner et il se fait
arnaquer c'est terrible il va tenter
sûrement cavalier des cinq pour essayer
de contrôler la case mais on n'arrive
pas à toucher le pion F3
Maxime qui va s'incliner
première partie très mal payée pour
Maxime ça aurait mériter nettement mieux
et là je vois des scénarios positifs
allez tout radins qui prend des cartes
ça dégage la racaille là le Fou est
cloué bon ça ça s'appelle un pion Magnus
oh bah oui ça c'est ça c'est
intervention de la police bakistanaise
ici cavalier prend le 5 cavalier prend
le 5 il faut prendre le 5 ah bah police
police
vos papiers s'il vous plaît monsieur
Carlson
ça va être pris hein Maxime qui
réfléchit il comprend pas ça ça
s'appelle un punto en langage maximesque
oh bah oui là c'est ça va être pris je
vous annonce Maxime qui vérifie quand
même surpris lui-même de la faiblesse du
coup mais ça va être mangé H4 à la fin
oui bon il y a aussi ton fout des quatre
qui va tomber oh bah c'est pris avec le
fou ça marche aussi et ça va prendre 5
ça s'appelle un punto donc Maxime qui
récupère le Punto et regarder ce fou mal
placé dame F6 ou dame B6 c'est cavaliers
des 7 monsieur Carlsen ça a été raté
cavalier des 7 sur dame B6 oh bah oui ça
s'appelle une fourchette et ça s'appelle
40 secondes d'avance le cavalier qui va
revenir ah bah ça c'est une dame par
contre oh oui ça c'est une dame allez
c'est pas c'est pas gagné allez tomber 8
tours des 8 échec allez Maxime fois
accélérer et fou des quatre cahier prend
ses 6 faut prendre deux rois j'ai deux
tours 2
c'est encore dangereux ça c'est
dangereux pour
à l'encontre de Maxime plutôt il a
vraiment pas de bol en ce début de match
notre max allez c'est bien joué là ce
qu'il a fait tout deux
mais il est complètement enfermé avec le
roi
et te retrouver deux rois F3 obligé de
prendre nul ici Maxime il a envie de
jouer le gars mais il peut pas
max ouais non là Magnus franchement le
jazz comme ça genre dégoûté alors que
tes dominé toute la partie on te voit
quand même hein fais pas semblant
d'avoir été mieux ça dégoûte ça ouais en
mode j'ai raté le gain n'importe quoi
non mais il se tient par par le bout
d'une liane et il vient de Nelly j'ai
raté le gars non mais c'est
insupportable allez Maxime
maintenant le cavalier qui vit en E5
quai vers D3 et la tour en C8 même
peut-être la Tour Eiffel et le cavalier
en Détroit et plus de 12 secondes ça sue
oh il y a peut-être des cavaliers F3
haut il y a peut-être des fous proches 3
aussi un jour il y a peut-être des fous
proches trois cavaliers F3 d'un match 2
si le cavalier par 35 mais oui c'est le
champagne ici tour C8 tours français 5
puisses secondes pour Magnus ça va
craquer let's go ça va faire Punto ça
plus 3 secondes il faut jouer monsieur
oh on va pas falloir dire qu'il a perdu
autant celle-là aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe c'est pas fait maintenant il est
gagnant mais c'est pas gagné enfin il
est il est très avantageux mais c'est
pas gagné encore bon ça par contre il y
a pas qu'à étranger 3 c'est ton jeu de
laisser gagner c'est le Punto ça dégage
la racaille let's go maxi let's go
ah merde
oh terrible Maxime qui a raté ah non
quelle horreur le pion haché est trop
fort maintenant
ah le piège à la con qui tombe
et qui nous fait très mal
ah
on est mat ah là là là là là là
ah [ __ ] quel dommage retour C4 c'est
bien joué
oh [ __ ] il y a tourbillon
[ __ ]
c'est pas possible
et il y a plus qu'à aider cette on prend
des 8 tours D8 ce que le royaume fuit
[ __ ]
B4 intermédiaire donc la dame va
repartir
je pars en B6 si là ça 5 il va repartir
en B8 et pour jouer pour eux 5 ouais
c'est bien joué il y a pas CD
d'apprendre des cartes maintenant quand
même c'est Punto et dame B7
il protège le pion il a quand même un
pion de plus la Maximin il va ouais
c'est quand même bon il joue pour
l'activité Magnus mais il donne des
pions ça prépare du F5 tours B8 et F5
elle se satané fou qui tape oh c'est
parti incroyable là de Magnus ouf
ah ouais celle-là elle fait mal à la
tête celle-là elle fait très mal quand
Magnus joue comme ça il est très dur à
prendre
et là Maxime va pouvoir mettre deux
échecs
mais le roi va partir vers H3 Tom c'est
7 encore quand même mais bon il y a 10
000 manières pour pour les blancs et
probablement tout et fuite
rouage 7 damage 5 ah ouais c'est toi
impressionnant
Max qui a le bon plan de jeu qui fait
tout ce qu'il faut mais il tombe sur sur
un Magnus des grands jours
pas de cours en fait
il y a juste pas de coup
allez Maxime qui tente un dernier truc
c'est trop solide il y a même pas de
magouille il va y avoir juste 3G 8 tours
F7 oh bien joué de la part de Maxime
quand même
il va peut-être faire dame 6 ah mais en
plus sur à échec
c'est fou cette
et là sur cavalier 4 il y a juste dame 8
oh il dégoûte
oh il dégoûte avec une seconde de
Magnus pour le moment qui tient
qui tient avec le fou et tout à cette
intermédiaire faut prendre des quatre il
va y avoir un problème avec le fou il y
aura pas fou aussi
c'est tellement bien joué c'est
stratosphérique en fait c'est fou prends
des cartes qui prend des quatre et on a
plus de fou aussi
mais bon encore tout recettes peut-être
cavalier 6 vous prend ces 6
en fait
les amis le niveau de jeu auquel on est
en train d'assister côté Carlsen et
absolument stratosphérique mais il y a
toujours ce pion c'est passé qui gêne et
ce roi mal placé là-bas
Maxime allez faut aller le matin
quel game de Maxime quand même en
défense qui donne tout pour rester dans
le match aller une fourchette allez une
fourchette pour le baume au coeur allez
il faut tenter un piège ouais il va
prendre la nul Maxime bêtement
et c'est déjà pas si mal et ce qui peut
réussir à jouer le gain il va mettre les
pions sur noir quand même
malheureusement il peut pas faire mieux
que nul ici
mais c'est les moyens énormes parties de
Maxime qui sauve à demi point mais à
quel prix il faut le battre combien de
fois avant de gagner un point en fait
c'est difficile à terminer allez
peut-être une tour sur la 6e
pour aller doubler quattro c'est bien
joué mais le cavalier qui contrôle tout
il va échanger les pièces les unes après
les autres et il va pas y en avoir assez
pour l'emporter
mais oui il a réussi à tout bloquer avec
son cheval
il est hyper solide une nouvelle fois
Maxime qui va pas réussir à gagner ouais
mais c'est trop en fait
ça défend trop fort
et ça ça gagne pas bon alors du monde
qui a que roi G7 qui défend j'ai 5 et
roissent retournent non mais bon [ __ ]
mais c'est pas possible
non mais t'as pas le droit d'avoir
autant de chatte quand même
non mais c'est trop
donne en ville on voit un H4 et en
éclaireur le roi qui vit en G2 qui vient
se placer tour des deux là il y a du
tour prend B6 il le trouve c'est trouvé
par Maxime
Magnus qui vient de gaver enfin Maxime
réussit à le faire craquer une première
fois en tout cas
Maxime qui essaie de jouer avec ça oh là
il y a tout reprend F3
Benga Benga c'est payé
ça ça s'appelle une pièce il l'avait vu
aussi ça et ben voilà allez mon Maxime
ça sourit un peu enfin il peut pas avoir
de la chatte pendant tout ce [ __ ] de
match c'est pas possible enfin Maxime on
le voit un peu sourire mais il en peut
plus il a une chatte elle est
monstrueuse
un Kraken bien sûr il avait roi j'ai 7
tout à l'heure oui bien sûr il avait
absolument rien et là il a encore de la
chagate parce que c'est même pas clair
ce truc
[ __ ] mais c'est pas possible en fait
ça rend fou mais ça rend fou
Maximilien arrive ok ça c'est un choix
bizarre de la part de Magnus
il faut qu'elle soit gagnante celle là
je crois qu'elle l'est
pas
il y a pas de zouk
un petit poucet 3 tranquillou
regarde cette jolie pièce
30 secondes d'avance c'est bien aussi
cavalier qui arrive en E4 les maximes
qui posent les choses comme ça ah sur
sur la configuration des parties les pas
loin la tour des 4 ça donne juste envie
de jouer bah c'est là qui pêche Maxime
et parce qu'il a pas la confiance parce
qu'il a pas mis les puntos plus tôt
c'est là qui péchotte un peu c'est au
moment de conclure
[ __ ] il gaffe encore mais c'est pas
possible et on l'a vu il a instantané
vendu Maxime qu'il avait gaffé et tout
ça c'est lié à la confiance maximim
aurait gagné les premières game ça
aurait pas du tout été ce scénario
et maintenant c'est terrible allez
cavaliers 4 cavaliers
ah non ça gagne pas du coup encore allez
roi B6 et à 6 à 7
voilà
non il a gaffe
à 7 tours à 7 on reprend F5
il a raté le gars là en fait là sur ton
A7 il fait Tour Eiffel intermédiaire ou
apprend à 7 et gagner
c'est quand même dangereux ouh là ouais
en fait cavalier F4 d'un F1 dans 5 ah
ouais en fait ça sue c'est peut-être pas
ça a l'air d'être prépa
il y a toutes les pièces qui arrivent ça
fait très très mal regardez ce cavalion
F4 qui a largement la valeur d'une tour
quelle niveau de jeu de Magnus alors il
commence par H5
waouh
cavalier G2 sortie de la boîte quelle
défense de Maxime encore une fois
le niveau de jeu est puissant de la part
du joueur français waouh trouver
cavalier H5 cavalier 3 pour cavalier
pour cavalier F2 Roy géanti G2 c'est
c'est du très très haut niveau ce que
vient de faire Maxime là trouver ce
cavalier G2 c'est exceptionnel et ça va
forcer Magnus à prendre la nul
c'est bizarre là ce qu'il fait
il s'est fait magouiller Maxime terrible
il a trop voulu jouer le gain et là il
va y avoir fou à 8 heures et c'est
terrible
il a voulu il a voulu la forcer
un peu dans l'urgence
du score
et Magnus qui est en train de oh c'est
magnifique ce que fait Magnus qu'est-ce
que c'est bien joué bravo à lui ouais
terrible ça va il va sûrement la gagner
Maxime celle-là
celle-là il va sûrement la gagner le roi
va passer devant
il est complètement enfermé ma gnous
ça là il peut pas la rater les noirs
sont complètement bloqués d'eau il a
juste plus de coups et la roi des 6
allez let's go
ça en fait une pour Maxime le score est
tellement c'est incroyable de perdre le
3 plus simple vu comment maxime a dominé
c'est incroyable mais la dame a cinko
tourner encore ça va
haut et des cas jolie surprise des
quatre prises des 4 il y avait dameurs
mat et Magnus qui a deux nouveaux une
bonne position tellement fort ce soir
allez peut-être un problème au temps
pour les Noirs il y a 5 points d'écart
c'est le moment de marquer un punto le
G4 de Maxime party vite qui a mis très
bien Maxime qui a espéré que la tour
revienne en la dame revienne en U2 mais
ça pas été fait il tourne il échange et
il va pas réussir à la gagner Magnus
Maxime va la tenir allez encore un petit
espoir un film
il va faire F5 F6 Maxime qui va même
peut-être jouer le gain non il va pas
pouvoir
il va tenter ça mais H6 joue à tempo
très bien fait de la part de Magnus il
va peut-être se faire couper le roi en
même temps
et je pense que ça va faire nul
rapidement minus vous allez voir qu'il
va répéter non il se il arrive quand
même
ouais une petite carisation de Magnus
ici non quand même pas on envoie Magnus
qui veut pas faire les choses comme un
certain streamer
correct quand même le joueur norvégien a
souligné c'est pas du hasard ça va
échanger côté Maxime non pas du tout
est-ce que cavalier prend F5 marche on
ne sait pas allez Maxime qui a réussi à
tourner avec le cheval et tout quoi trop
il enferme la dame
il y a pas fou prends le cavalier H3 le
coup de marlou il est pas bien ma douche
allez ça revient à 4 points à mon
maximum allez let's go
allez il faut la gagner il faut la
terminer
oh les cavaliers prend F2 mais oui
monsieur
et là c'est Damas donc cavalier G4
manus qui rigole mais qui rigole pas
tant que ça bon voilà c'est Dame ranger
7 et là ça va commencer à jouer le temps
côté Magnus on va voir son vrai visage
manuscrit le remet encore une nouvelle
fois il supplice ouverture a été très
bien gérée de la part du joueur
norvégien face au champion du monde
un Maxime qui décide de filer le Punto
carrément
la position est vraiment difficile
il espère enfermer la dame elle va
repartir vers B7 et là il y a ces cinq
qui va partir ouais Magnus carmien un
coup un coup d'accélérateur là tout d'un
coup et ça nous a fait tout drôle ouais
Maxime on a gagné une mais alors là
c'est l'accélérateur ça fait très très
mal parti exemplaire de la part de
Magnus qui a dominé dans l'ouverture
Maxime qui abandonne et là les cinq
points on les reverra plus les amis et
on voit un Maxime qui a essayé de
d'éviter l'espagnol mais qui se met dans
des positions très difficiles ça ça va
être du F5 H4
qui va partir
la FCO fait mal le cavalier a plu
énormément de cases et maintenant CF4 et
c'est le fou qui va se retrouver piégé
après quoi trop c'est pas joué pour le
moment si fash 4 il y a encore fou et 5
allez encore une petite chansette vous
prend ces 7 pour Maxime il voulait on
apprend ses 7 qui est B5 mesdames G7
tape sur G2 et si Maxime percel là alors
là ça y est - 6 c'est mathématiquement
terminé à 100% victoire de Magnus
Carlsen
[Musique]